you're talking to your clients your
client asks you
hey tom man what do i do i sell my
business
do i what recommendation are you given
are you saying
sell this year rather than next year are
you saying
look are you keeping it for five ten
years who cares hang on to it
if you know what kind of feedback are
you giving i know obviously you can't
give a blanket advice to everybody
but what are some of the feedback you're
given to your clients no
look once you understand the tax law you
realize that there are a lot of
different options
there are a lot of different ways to go
and and you know my job for example is
to
help you do what you want to do and not
pay tax that's my job
and so we there there are ways there are
always going to be ways to deal with
this okay we can deal with the capital
gains tax now
what i am telling every client is do
your estate planning now
uh you asked the question patrick
earlier could they go back to
the beginning of the year that is really
horrible
horrible policy okay could they do it
maybe i don't know i mean i i'm not sure
that that's legal
to go back could they go back to today
yeah i mean
if you look at this 2017 act um
that's that was retroactive to september
right september 27th
is when those provisions were
retroactive most of them were
retroactive to september 27th
well that's when the legislation was
first proposed and so that's not unusual
uh now we don't yet have legislation
actually proposed we just have guidance
ideas we don't have actual legislation
yet so what we're hopeful at
that we have the small window of
opportunity right now
um to do some good estate and income tax
planning and they always go together by
the way you never do a state plan
without doing income tax planning you
have to do them together
um but if you do that right now there's
at least
a hope that uh you're gonna you're gonna
be within the window if you don't do it
now
and you wait till the end of the year
and it passes then
you know you know you're gonna be stuck
states a lot of people are looking into
moving to different states
okay a lot of people when i met with
arthur laffer in tennessee i said why
are you in tennessee he said it's the
lowest all-in taxes in all of america
and he's not from nashville tennessee
you moved his practice to nashville
tennessee
what are some states that are winning
right now what are some states that
uh people ought to consider and what are
some deciding factors on somebody to sit
there and said i should look at this
state that state and this state
well um first of all look at all the
taxes don't just look at income tax
okay because every state has to have
money
and they just get it different ways
whether it's sales tax or property tax
income tax those are pretty much the
three legs of the stool right
the income stool for a state um texas
obviously is winning florida is winning
uh those are the two big winners right
now um
south dakota should be winning right um
it doesn't have a tax
and like say tennessee has a they have
actually they have a low personal income
tax but they actually have a pretty high
uh business income tax so it's uh
tennessee's
probably would not be my first choice i
would probably choose a texas
um and texas even better than florida
because florida does have a corporate
income tax they just don't have a
personal income tax uh wyoming nevada
no income taxes so i think those are
kind of the the winners of course you
have to look at
you know where do you want to live uh i
think that's more important
texas does raise a lot of their revenue
from property tax so you have to look at
okay what are my property tax going to
look like and um do i
do i even care right um but it is those
states with low income tax or no income
tax
that are really the big winners right
now i mean even even like
i mean take um i'm in arizona
and the surrounding states not arizona
itself because we just
increased our taxes by 80 it's just
lovely what we did
um so now what we have is we have utah
new mexico colorado all with
much lower tax rates than arizona so i
don't think arizona is going to be the
big growth state
if this prop 208 stands up
in court if it stands up in court then i
think that we're going to go the way of
california
i think the west coast and the east
coast outside of
again florida i think they're pretty
much toast
people are just going to keep moving out
unless they want to pay the high
what i call a beach tax um that to you
know to live in those states
but um the middle america i think is
winning
they're winning with um you know they're
winning they they've won throughout the
pandemic
frankly is that they've got lower tax
rates they
they are more conservative governments
and uh and people are moving there in
the droves
first time in 172 years california's
population
didn't grow that's pretty insane to be
thinking about that first time in 127
years
172 years well and and and what did they
do they they suggest we ought to have a
16.9 percent tax
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye